[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de los
observadores de france 24 esta semana
iremos al rol de china donde las
autoridades decretaron un nuevo
confinamiento tras la reaparición de un
foco de ccoo el 19 luego a serbia a un
lago transformado en vertedero y
finalmente terminamos con la noticia
falsa de la semana
[Aplausos]
[Música]
los habitantes de shijiazhuang conocen
muy bien este ruido es de las máquinas
de desinfección de las calles la razón
desde comienzos de enero la ciudad
conoce una explosión en el número de
casos de kobe 19 primera vez en china
desde hace 5 meses consecuencia los
habitantes de la provincia de hebei
están sometidos a medidas de
confinamiento estrictas y a campañas
masivas de pruebas algunos habitantes
como basa y documenta su cotidianidad en
turín el equivalente chino de 'tik tok'
acabo de oír los llamar a nuestro
edificio desde abajo empezó la cuarta
sesión de pruebas nucleicos en silla
swan
tendremos que hacernos pruebas una vez
cada dos días durante las próximas dos
semanas este es el punto donde se hacen
las pruebas las personas ya están
haciendo la fila un empleado le pide a
todo el mundo mantenerse a un metro de
distancia ya casi es mi turno
le ponen mucha atención a los mayores
listo termine mi prueba ahora se procede
la desinfección aún así las hay se
siente contenta en su barrio los
habitantes tienen acceso a una gran
variedad de productos en las tiendas de
alimentos que permanecen abiertas no
estamos autorizados a salir de nuestro
barrio entonces hago todas mis compras
cerca de mi casa miren esta abundancia
hay de todo aquí hasta ahora ningún
almacén ha aumentado sus precios
por ejemplo esta caja de huevos
normalmente cuesta 60 yuanes y ahora
hasta 55 iguales
y sencilla uso no todos los habitantes
de hebei tuvieron la posibilidad de
quedarse confinados en sus casas más de
1000 personas que vivían en pueblos
considerados de alto riesgo fueron
evacuados hacia centros de cuarentena
especiales
bajo esta capa de desechos esconde un
lago el pod pec en el suroeste de serbia
a finales de 2020 se transformó en un
verdadero vertedero flotante cuando
alrededor de 20.000 metros cúbicos de
desechos plásticos se acumularon cerca
de una represa tras fuertes lluvias
y es un fenómeno recurrente tal como lo
explica nuestro observador a axel a
músico una gran parte de la superficie
del agua estaba cubierta por una gruesa
capa de botellas de plástico de cajas de
plástico de llantas de carros de
pequeños aparatos electrónicos y de
muchas otras cosas el río el imn hace en
montenegro luego llega poco a poco al
lago la contaminación del río aumenta
porque cada vez hay más vertederos
ilegales
y también hay personas que tiran sus
desechos directamente al río link
una de las causas de la contaminación es
el vertedero de stang y bina
a finales de diciembre una gran cantidad
de desechos llegó al lago tras un
periodo de fuertes lluvias que
arrastraron los desechos a lo largo del
río lynn michaels a lo que es ahora
[Música]
el problema de la contaminación del lago
es una amenaza para muchos animales y
plantas que el dinero de mis sinde ya
tienen la única solución para
sensibilizarnos es invertir aún más en
la educación sobre el tratamiento de los
desechos
[Música]
así es como podremos salvar lo que la
naturaleza nos ha dado donde es fácil o
nos permitan entre verdad
y terminamos con nuestro episodio de la
noticia falsa con dos informaciones
falsas sobre el presidente
estadounidense joe by lnd
uy si fuera republicano la vigésimo
quinta enmienda estaría en el centro del
debate y por buenas razones
unos soldados estadounidenses le dan la
espalda vaivén mientras se dirige hacia
el capitolio al parecer no comparten el
entusiasmo de los medios recién
posesionado como presidente de eeuu joe
wire en ya enfrenté informaciones falsas
con primer vídeo publicado por donald
trump juniors pretende que no sabe lo
que hace y en un segundo vídeo se
trataría incluso de militares que le
dieron la espalda al presidente electo
veamos el primer vídeo en esta
publicación el hijo de donald trump
evoca la vigesimoquinta enmienda que
permite destituir un presidente que ya
no está en capacidad para gobernar una
referencia directa a la edad de joe
biden 78 años que sus detractores
presentan como senil pero en realidad el
fragmento está truncado en la versión no
recortada se ve claramente que joe biden
está acompañado y que está esperando a
esas dos personas que se encuentran a la
derecha para salir del recinto con ellas
ahora el vídeo de los militares le
dieron voluntariamente la espalda al
presidente electo esto fue lo que nos
contestó la guardia nacional estos
militares estaban en servicio y tenían
la misión de proteger al presidente de
posibles amenazas algunos dan la espalda
con el fin de asegurar la seguridad de
todos al observar otras imágenes de la
investidura de uairén vemos que algunos
militares
el presidente electo pero otros no es el
caso de todas las investiduras incluida
la de donald trump en 2017 aquí vemos
unos hombres dar la espalda y otro mirar
de frente a la caravana presidencial
estos dos vídeos sobre la investidura de
joe bites son entonces informaciones
falsas cuyo objetivo es denigrar al
presidente electo muestra que no hay que
detenerse solo en el subtítulo de un
vídeo y que es necesario siempre tratar
de entender el contexto de una
publicación
esto fue todo por esta semana no dude en
escribirnos por twitter facebook
whatsapp a nuestros contactos que
aparecen en pantalla esperamos sus
imágenes para cubrir juntos lo que
ocurre cerca de ustedes hasta pronto
[Música]